[Musik]
in china setzten viele der großen
lebensmittelkonzerne auf eine
technologie namens
kann blog chaney herkunft unserer
lebensmittel dokumentieren kann ich
bestimmte informationen in die kette
einfügen eine sehr gute frage das ist
eine große chance für die technologie
man nimmt an den nfc-chip zum scannen
und jetzt verifiziert die app die
identität der flasche
in diesem zweiten teil unseres spezials
über block chain finde ich heraus was
das internet der dinge gegen gefälschte
lebensmittel tun kann
die welt wird immer verrückter
und komplizierter
deshalb bin ich wieder da um ihnen zu
helfen den sinn zu verstehen dieses mal
bringe ich ihn einen besseren zugang
spannende geschichten und tiefere
einblicke ich werde ihnen sagen warum
das wichtig ist
ich bin in der provinz liaoning einem
wasser um mich herum sind millionen von
sekunden
das können sie selbst sehen
was ich meine ist sie können sich die
überwachungsvideos der aquakultur fahren
hier auf der chinesischen e commerce
website die dot com ansehen niederkorn
auf der webseite wechselt das was sie
sehen zufällig zwischen den fast 100
kameras
[Musik]
lieferanten jangtse food company hat
beschlossen die aufnahmen seinem blog
chain hochzuladen die man dann auf der
webseite und der mobilen anwendung von
jenny dot com sehen kann sie möchten
dass die verbraucher die herkunft und
echtheit ihrer sie gucken selbst
überprüfen kann
[Musik]
warum sollte ein unternehmen so viel
aufwand betreiben um die herkunft
nachzuweisen ich habe mich darüber
gewundert bis ich feststellte dass es
einen enormen preisunterschied zwischen
sekunden an verschiedenen orten geerntet
wurden
nehmen sie zum beispiel dieser sieg sie
sehen gleich aus aber ich finde schnell
heraus dass die eine 600 dollar mehr
kostet als die andere denn die
lagerung zubereitung von seegurken
gedacht ist es ist eine spezialität
dieses restaurants dass seine fast
90-jährigen geschichte in peking hat und
hier ist auch der chefkoch antwort der
schon seit 40 jahren hier arbeitet
meister an glaubens zu viele arten von
seegurken gibt
ich würde sie gerne testen die sechs
gruppen arten hier kosten zwischen 800
und 5.000 jahren
jeder hat einen anderen preis ich möchte
dass ihr sie nach preis sortieren
ok ich werde mal raten ich mein
begrenztes wissen übersee gruppen weiß
ich mehr starten sie haben desto teurer
sind sie
lassen sie mich versuchen zu erraten
welches die billigste ist ok also ich
nehme die mit den wenigsten stacheln
diese hier hat ziemlich kurze starren
aber sie sieht ein bisschen
verschrumpelt oder ein bisschen faltig
aus
ich würde sagen dass das die billigste
ist
die seegurke hat die meisten stacheln
und die länge des stacheln es auch
ziemlich lang
musste von allen sechs arten die hier
sehe also schätze ich das ist die
teuerste und
dadurch recht sie haben recht das ist
die billigste und das ist die teuerste
also hatte ich recht die kostet ungefähr
1000 jahren
das ist die teuerste sie kommt aus
japans kanto region sie kostet etwa 5000
yuan pro 600 gramm sie sind also ein
experte fürs ego aber wie sieht es mit
den normalen chinesen als die auf dem
markt gehen und seegurken kaufen wissen
die genau so viel wie sie
der mann auf der straße weiß vielleicht
nicht wirklich wie man sehr guten ernte
chinas wirtschaft hat sich erst in den
letzten dreißig bis vierzig jahren
geöffnet
lebensstandard der einfachen leute ist
erst in den letzten jahrzehnten
gestiegen früher hätten sich die meisten
leute sehr guten nicht leisten können
ich habe gelernt dass hochwertigen
seegurken aus leon ihn ziemlich viel
geld kosten weil die gewässer in denen
sie aufwachsen kälter sind
wenn es um betrug geht related desy
campus werden den verbrauchern meistens
seegurken minderer qualität zu höheren
preisen verkauft premium crisis
niemand stirbt aber die menschen sind
verständlicherweise verärgert dass sie
nicht die qualität bekommen die ihnen
versprochen wurde
[Musik]
die new york stellt seine seegurken auf
die blogs um den kunden zu versichern
dass die gekauften seegurken jeden cent
wert
[Musik]
ich treffe die schranken und ziehen
europe ihre aufgabe ist es
sicherzustellen dass jede seegurke die
produziert wird die hohen standards
erfüllt die die kunden erwarten
was wollen sie den kunden zeigen
die daten die wir unseren kunden geben
stamm von dieser tat fähig sie zeigen
wie das produkt verarbeitet wird wann
und unter welchen bedingungen es
hergestellt wird
anhand dieser informationen können
unsere kunden im detail nachvollziehen
wie und wann das produkt verarbeitet
wurde und wieder aufzucht prozess
wir hoffen auf diese weise das vertrauen
unserer kunden zu gewinnen
durch die kette von daten gibt es keine
verwirrung mehr über die herkunft
zeige ihnen jetzt unseren kühlraum na ja
und jetzt richten wir unsere
hört sich nach einem transparenten
prozess
ich herausfinde dass die daten manuell
eingegeben
also bleibt die gefahr menschlicher
fehler warum sollte ich also abgesehen
von den überwachungsbehörden und
informationen vertrauen
ich wende mich anziehen long blog zehn
anbieter die um antworten zu bekommen
kann ich bestimmte informationen
festlegen und auf die ketten setzten
sehr gute frage sie haben einen guten
blick in das geschäft in der tat ist das
eine große chance für die technologie
zum beispiel können wir die ios geräte
verwenden um einige der informationen zu
sammeln wie die temperatur die umwelt
variablen und diese informationen dann
direkt in die block chain einspeisen
ich verstehe es muss also ein
maschineller prozess sein keine
menschliche ein menschlicher man braucht
also eine ganze infrastruktur damit das
ganze tracking system auf der block 10
realisiert werden kann
[Musik]
das internet der dinge das
bezieht sich auf ein netzwerk von
geräten es ist nicht nur eines der
großen schlagworte in der geschäftswelt
in der sonnen verändert auch unseren
alltag
schon heute können sie für wenig geld
ihr smartphone so einrichten dass es mit
allen elektrischen geräten in ihrem haus
verbunden ist
um das licht zu steuern ihre
lieblingsmusik zu spielen hier ist ein
spotify oder
[Musik]
luft zu können damit es sich gut anfühlt
wenn man nach hause kommt
der haken an der sache ist es kostet
nicht viel das eigene haus intelligenter
zu machen bei kleinen bis mittleren
unternehmen dürfte das mehrere
zehntausend euro kosten
das klingt nach einem kostspieligen
unterfangen und müsste der verbraucher
einen teil der kosten übernehmen die
kosten für die einrichtungen der ersten
block chain anwendungen sind meistens
hoch
aber solange man den anwendungsbereich
und umfang erweitert gleichen sich die
kosten am ende aus
also kostet es am ende wenig das ist
auch der grund warum in den nächsten
fünf jahren wenn die blogs chain
technologie zum industriestandard wird
die kosten niedriger sein werden
also jetzt weiß ich dass die blog chain
zwar verschlüsselt gibt aber nur so
zuverlässig ist in die daten aus denen
sie gespeist wird
aber selbst wenn die daten stimmen
was ist wenn das produkt
die url verweist immer noch auf dem
selben link in der block chain aber das
produkt ist nicht mehr dasselbe
bitcoin mag die schlagzeilen beherrschen
aber die technologie hinter der krippe
währung kann mehr dumont
in china wird die block chain zur
rückverfolgung von lebensmitteln
eingesetzt
das heißt dass man wichtige
informationen über produkte ablesen kann
ihn zwar hiermit
ein qr-code also ein quick response code
es kleine brücke er verbindet das
produkt in der physischen welt mit
information in der digitalen welt
diese muss da können wir von maschinen
gelesen werden wenn man also einen qr
codes kennt übersetzen die maschinen das
information die wir lesen kann
es gibt auch nfc die
nahfeldkommunikation
nfc gehört zu einer technologie namens
rfid
radiofrequenz-identifikation rfid
wird jeder gegenstand funkwellen
eindeutig identifiziert bei nfc werden
die daten sicherer oder eine höhere
frequenz übertragen wenn es und zwar mit
einem chip
[Musik]
das lockt change we choose eines der
wenigen unternehmen der branche dass
seine eigenen sensoren entwickelt und
herstellt
hier stellen wir unsere chips her es
gibt verschiedene arten
hier haben wir qr codes
ist der enercity man kann ihnen auf der
verpackung anbringen wenn man sie öffnet
wird die antenne zerstört das hier ist
eine neue generation
er enthält sowohl ard als auch nfc
das ist sehr einfach sehr unternehmens
freundlich und areva die ist im lager
sehr nützlich man kann es aus großer
entfernung scannen und die produkte in
stapeln erfassen aber
gleichzeitig braucht darf die ein
spezielles lesegerät so dass es für den
endverbraucher nicht sehr einfach zu
benutzen ist wenn es also in einem
geschäft ankommt kann man nur nfc
benutzen
verbraucher können ein nfc einfach mit
ihrem handy scannen
es gibt unterschiedliche bedürfnisse für
die lager und die verbraucher
als junge
[Musik]
welche möglichkeiten gibt es auf einen
block chain zuzugreifen
es spielt keine rolle ob das ein qr-code
ein rfid oder ein nfc chip ist
es ist nur eine möglichkeit das produkt
zu kennzeichnen
wir entwickeln verschiedene methoden die
auf derart und auch auf dem wert des
produkts basieren wenn man das produkt
mit einem chip versieht sind die kosten
natürlich höher als bei einem qr-code
wir arbeiten mit einigen weinkellereien
und weinproduzenten zusammen sie haben
viele hochwertige weine die über 1000
türen oder so kosten
[Musik]
ist also der wein und hier ist der nfc
chip hier sehen sie wie er angebracht
wird sie nehmen den nfc-chip um ihn zu
scannen
verifiziert die app die identität dieser
flasche sobald das passiert ist können
sie sehen das ist eine eindeutige id und
wenn sie mehr informationen wollen dann
haben sie die produktgeschichte die
beschreibung und in der realen welt
haben sie auch logistische informationen
welche technologie wird der schlüssel
zum blog geschenkt in der zukunft sein
die antwort ist nicht offensichtlich
bedenken sie folgendes konzept
ist ein 2007 rotwein des berühmten
mammuts
wenn er das ist was er zu sein vorgibt
kostet er stolze 900 dollar
wenn er es nicht ist
seien sie beruhigt sie sind
wahrscheinlich nicht allein denn es ist
einer der am meisten gefälschten weine
in china man würde erwarten dass der
vertreiber solch seltener weine die
staatliche direct.de auf die nfc
technologie setzt
die sichere und anpassbarer ist
aber das ist nicht der fall
so was sehen wir hier
man kann leicht herausfinden wann der
wein kommt und von welchem wein gut also
es gibt
ja das weingut wurde 1882 gegründet das
ist ein sehr traditioneller
familienbetrieb
[Musik]
im zentrum hat mehr als 200 mitglieder
sie sind alle an einem rückverfolgung
system interessiert die versuchen den
gesamten chinesischen markt zu
vermitteln dass man wein auf viel
sicherere weise genießen kann aber wenn
wir über die kosten sprechen sagen sie
okay das ist zu viel für uns über drei
jahren haben wir die verbände das
kostete fast einen yuan pro chip aber
jetzt nehmen wir
kosten vielleicht sind wir
wollen dass mehr unternehmen sich uns
anschließen müssen wir die kosten für
die tags oder chips senken
langfristig gleichen sich die kosten
also aus und der eigentliche gewinn ist
die sicherheit die sie ihren kunden
geben können oder
darauf stoßen wir an ok die zeugen sie
das glas heben oder
[Musik]
qr-codes kosten weniger
unternehmen bevorzugen sie um auf
informationen in ihrem blog chains
zuzugreifen mit haken ist was ist wenn
ich das mache ich
mache eine kopie des qr codes
und
oder dass hier
die url verweist immer noch auf den
selben link in der box aber das produkt
wurde verändert
[Musik]
in china spielt die block 1 bereits eine
große rolle bei der sicherung der
lebensmittel
viele lebensmittel hanko er kurz die
darüber informieren woher sie kommen
aber mir ist klar dass qr-codes alles
andere als narrensicher sind wenn ich
wollte eigentlich den inhalt leicht
manipulieren die url verweist immer noch
auf dem selben link in der block chain
haben aber das produkt wurde verändert
um dies zu verhindern hat der teck und
arminias berlinski eine intelligente
verpackungslösung entwickelt ja es ist
mitbegründer von meinem blog chain
startup das baby nahrung in china
importiert und vertreibt
wenn man sich die branche anguckt gibt
es ziemlich viele behauptungen und einen
hype um die block c sie würde das
problem der fälschungen lösen aber das
ist einfach nicht der fall denn selbst
wenn man den gefälschten quellcode
scannt erhält man das ergebnis dieses
datensatzes der in der block schein
existiert
und was noch schlimmer ist als das
produkt nicht zu schützen ist dass es
ihnen ein gefühl der sicherheit gibt
dass das produkt sich mit der block
chain zu authentifizieren scheint also
muss es war sein und das ist der grund
warum die blogger im moment das problem
der fälschungen nicht alleine lösen kann
man braucht dafür zusätzlich etwas und
das tun wir und was ist dieses extra
blog chain wirklich sicher zu machen
das ist im wesentlichen ein physischer
schutz des produkts man muss
sicherstellen dass es diese 11
korrespondenz zwischen block chain und
einem physischen objekt gibt etwas das
man nicht in einer unendlichen anzahl
von kopien reproduzieren kann so etwas
wir uns ausgedacht haben das ist eine
der älteren generationen des etiketts
aber es funktioniert immer noch gleich
sie sehen hier wir schützen das produkt
nicht nur auf der blog chain also
digital sondern auch physisch
der anspruch den wir erheben und das
versprechen dass wir dem verbraucher
geben ist das wenn dieses ding
authentisch ist heißt das dass die
verpackung nicht manipuliert wurde
ein elektronisches gerät unter dem label
im grunde ist das ein label richtig es
basiert auf der nfc technologie und was
sie hier in dem schalk reich sehen ist
im wesentlichen eine antenne die mit
einem nfc-chip verbunden ist schauen sie
dieses zifferblatt füllt sich mit den
prozentsätzen das ist wenn die daten mit
der branche ausgetauscht werden alle
informationen wurden mit einer blocking
überprüft das ist also was der
verbraucher sieht richtig das sind alle
standard informationen die logistische
nachverfolgung infos über das produkt
und so weiter
was ist das sein die scan standorte
das ist eigentlich unser testmuster
also immer wenn wir es auf eine reise
zum vorzeigen mitgenommen haben wurde es
in der block 10 registriert
werden auch die daten auf einen
zusätzlichen blog gelegt und jedesmal
hinzugefügt wenn jemand den chips
zu den datensatz der genau zu diesem
produkt gehört ich verstehe warum ist
logwin also der richtige weg für sie
sehen sie wir sind nicht die ersten die
versuchen das problem mit den
fälschungen in china zu lösen
die verbraucher haben schon jeden glaubt
man solche behauptungen verloren
sie sagen mir dass sie nur echte sachen
verkaufen aber warum sollte ich ihnen
glauben es gibt zehn andere unternehmen
die das gleiche tun und sie scheitern
unweigerlich
wenn wir blog chain benutzen müssen sie
nicht uns vertrauen sondern der
technologie
solange sie also verstehen wie die
technologie funktioniert müssen wir
nicht überzeugend seien
sie authentifiziert uns also als
unternehmen
[Musik]
babys sind gestorben nachdem sie mit
melamin verseuchte milch getrunken haben
300.000 andere wurden krank verseuchte
chinesische mensch china skandal um
babymilchpulver auf der ganzen welt
wächst die sorge um die sicherheit
chinesischer milchprodukte
der milchpulver skandal von 2008 bei dem
sechs babys starben und 300.000 krank
wurden verfolgt die chinesen bis heute
der vertrauenskrise verschärfte sich als
ende 2015 ein weiterer skandal um
gefälschte milch in shanghai aufgedeckt
wurde
zwölf verdächtige wurden beschuldigt
billiges milchpulver als markenprodukt
ausgegeben zu haben über 12.000 dosen
mit marken milchprodukten waren
betroffen
ich bin ein vater das ist wichtig zu
wissen ob nämlich pulver gepanscht wurde
lehnten
ich möchte jahres lassen
ich treffe mich mit seinem
verkaufsleiter drama in einem wagen des
bio produkte verkauft was ist wenn ich
den aufkleber ganz vorsichtig abziehe
sodass der stromkreis nicht unterbrochen
wird
versuchen sie es versuchen sie es
versuchen ich glaube das schaffen sie
nicht
ja klar das ist unser physischer schutz
um jede art von wiederverwendung oder
recycling dieser produkte zu verhindern
aber noch etwas sie brauchen ihr handy
um es zu verfolgen wenn sie also das
etikett zerrissen oder kaputt gemacht
haben können sie nichts mehr scannen
weil der kreislauf unterbrochen ist die
antenne ist kaputt wenn die antenne
kaputt ist ist die verbindung zum
nfc-chip komplett unterbrochen
[Musik]
ich war ermutigt als sich china verließ
nicht durch den stand der technologie
die noch einen langen weg vor sich hat
bevor sie zum mainstream wird sondern
von den talentierten männern und frauen
die sich dem ziel verschrieben haben
eine bessere welt zu schaffen eine welt
in der wir unseren lebensmitteln
vertrauen können und genau deshalb ist
es so wichtig
[Musik]